we can no longer deny what is clear our
time on earth is ending alright so Chris
uh the other week we took a little trek
out to a fancy Science Center in Oakland
a giant telescope they had giant
telescopes and like Einsteins telescopes
and they also had for some reason they
had like all these computers in a room
with civilization beyond Earth was
awesome I don't know what that was is
science trip ever yeah we played like
100 they gave us a hundred turn start
from the beginning colonize a planet
flunk your butt down on there and see
how much this game is like other sibs
which it kind of is but it kind of isn't
also yeah it's it's sort of interesting
there's there's the immediate space
drama which of course always sucks me
and it's like boom you're saying you're
your pods sort of lands and suddenly
you're there and now we're kind of like
where it's sort of like sim five right
you've got hexes and you've got to start
creating units from your your core city
right and then you start sending them
out and in this case you send out
explorers yeah there's an explorer unit
which is like a little dude with like a
moon rover and they're kind of like
Scouts you know they can move further
their weak in combat but exploring on an
alien planet is a lot different than
exploring like whatever earth analog you
were on and civic AWS I think one of the
main reasons is because I mean it looks
different but we played the fungal biome
it's got like big purple landscapes in
mushroom forest and stuff but I the
aliens man the aliens yeah that's sort
of a wrench in the works right because
you go out there and I'm setting them
around and something so as some tiles
have like this foggy like poison look my
that's my asthma and then you've got
other places where you got sometimes you
got little like little mounds of aliens
going in and out they're not going to do
anything bad to you oh that's well
that's because they're like a restoring
right there was this sort of
identifiable you know like you bet you
work this hex you'll be getting plus two
production because it's got titan on it
or something but then you've got mean
things yeah and one of the first mean
things i ran into is like a trio of
space flies I'm gonna call them space
flies I don't know what their
they call so if you go out and you get
you you have to do with the space flies
you know you can bombard him in your
city and just just toss missiles Adam
from the city no big whoop right but if
you've got units out there you got to be
really careful because they're gonna be
really really tough yeah there are a few
things above that this is like their
home turf right so you've got space
flies you've got the Starship Troopers
sort of insect warriors you've got these
giant like manticores that are pulling
an acid at you they're like a ranged
unit if you think about them like
barbarians you're gonna be in a lot of
trouble because a there's more of them
and be there like more tenacious about
defending their territory and there but
they're also not always aggressive like
just because they're buzzing around
outside your city doesn't mean they're
going to actively mess with you they're
just kind of checking you out there's
actually like AI aggression levels for
the aliens and depending on like if you
go on rampage and you're killing sons of
aliens great for your military XP but
like then tougher aliens are gonna be
interested in your city and they can get
really tough there's like a giant dune
siege worm it can straight-up kill a
city but then it's not just the damage
the aliens do to your stuff and your
city and your troops but also the the
damage it can do to your relationships
with other civilizations because you
start attacking aliens enough and the
other sibs are going to stop are going
to be unhappy about that and one of the
reasons is because if you piss off the
aliens the aliens are pissed off at
everyone you've got them riled up within
the context of human history previous
civ games you kind of have an idea of
how it's going to go you start off in
your small villages and you got your
your spearmen but then you expand you
get your pikemen then you can take to
the seas right it's a course of human
history see beyond Earth's obviously a
whole new kind of history and so the
challenge is like all right what am I
reference points like how do i frame
this and one of the ways they do that is
obviously your tech research your
virtues choices all that stuff but also
quests which you start getting right
from the beginning and they're really
you know they're not some of them are
sort of go explore and find this thing
that they sort of teach you that like
you can explore and find good things but
others are just like thought experiments
almost it'll just be a paragraph won't
be like hey you guys have some old earth
relics right you brought with you some
people want to treat them like holy
relics and
sealed away and never actually seen by
the human eye and honored and sacred
other people want to like put them out
in a museum for people to check out and
learn from what do you think we should
do the choice is only a or b you know a
gives you a bonus to food be gives you a
bonus this science or whatever but it's
making you think about like what it's
like to start this new kind of world
this new society the outside post human
society I think it's a neat touch a new
beginning
for mankind